hi wir sind wieder für euch ZDF heute
live ganz herzlich willkommen bei uns im
Stream schön dass ihr bei uns seid bei
uns geht es heute um Geld es geht um
richtig viel Geld und natürlich auch um
das Geld von uns allen seit heute
Nachmittag sitzen die
Ministerpräsidenten und
Ministerpräsidenten mit Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz zusammen und sie beraten
über die Frage wer zahlt eigentlich die
zuletzt beschlossenen zwei
Milliardenhilfen hier haben wir Bilder
von heute Nachmittag als die Beteiligten
angekommen sind als sie eingetroffen
sind in Berlin zum Treffen mit Olaf
Scholz
da ging es Gast gegen das ganz rein
und jetzt gerade haben wir auch für euch
im Blick immer wieder die aktuellen
Bilder denn die Beteiligten haben uns
Antworten versprochen erste auf einer
Pressekonferenz sie haben wir die
Fotografinnen und Fotografen die schon
mal Fotos schießen wenn dann gleich die
beteiligten Männer die drei Herren
Stefan weil Hendrik wüst und auch Olaf
Scholz Platz nehmen werden die
Statements ihr seht natürlich live bei
uns gleich und auch die passende
Einordnung von unserer
hauptstadtkorrespondentin Nicole
Diekmann schönen guten Abend Nicole
schön dass du bei uns bist hallo danke
dass ich dabei sein darf Nicole du
verfolgst das mit uns das Drumherum um
diese Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz den
ganzen Tag was ist denn so atmosphärisch
bekannt wie ging das so hinter den
verschlossenen Türen umher was wir jetzt
schon wissen es hat schon mal länger
gedauert als ursprünglich angenommen
genau das wollte ich gerade sagen wir
schauen mal eben auf die Uhr
21 Uhr das ist relativ spät und ein
Zeichen für das was wir auch hören hier
im ZDF Hauptstadtstudio das ist nämlich
relativ hoch hergegangen ist
stellenweise in dieser
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz was aus ich
würde sagen drei Gründen nicht ganz
verwunderlich erst ist erstens es geht
um sehr viel Geld zweitens es war vor
dieser
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz nicht
geklärt wer wie viel Geld für was
bezahlen soll ich bin mir auch noch
nicht sicher ob das jetzt letztendlich
geklärt ist und drittens
fünf Tagen wird in Niedersachsen gewählt
das heißt da sitzt mit Stefan weil den
wir ja auch gleich bei der
Pressekonferenz sehen werden ein
Ministerpräsident mit in der Runde der
gerne wiedergewählt werden will das
macht sicherlich auch einen großen Teil
der Verhandlungen aus denn mit ihm
zusammensitzen da ja auch Vertreter
anderer Parteien die auch für einen
Wahlerfolg ihrer eigenen Partei in
Niedersachsen natürlich werben und
kämpfen ja absolut du hast schon
verschiedene Punkte angesprochen und ich
freue mich sehr dass du bei uns bist und
dass wir die auch später vertiefen
können bevor wir das machen zeigt uns
aber Carsten heckes erst einmal welche
Themen und welche Punkte darüber hinaus
heute da auf dem Tisch gekommen sind
bei den Beratungen im Kanzleramt ging es
vor allem um die schon Anfang September
beschlossenen 65 Milliarden Euro aus dem
dritten Entlastungspaket eine
energiepreispauschale für Rentner
einmalig 300 Euro für Studierende 200 €.
das Kindergeld für die ersten drei
Kinder wird zum ersten Januar um 18 Euro
angehoben auch eine wohngeldreform soll
für Entlastungen in Abhängigkeit von der
Haushaltsgröße sorgen mit der Einführung
des Bürgergelds erhalten Empfänger ab
kommenden Jahr rund 500 Euro im Monat
zuletzt ist der Bund auch bereit
jährlich 1,5 Milliarden Euro zusätzlich
für eine Nachfolgeregelung des
9-euro-tickets zu zahlen wenn die Länder
mindestens dieselbe Summe beisteuern die
Länder kritisieren dass sie sich nach
eigenen Berechnungen mit rund 19
Milliarden Euro an den dritten
Entlastungspaket beteiligen müssen umso
mehr wollen Sie wissen welche
Entlastungen der gerade erst am
Donnerstag
vorgestellte sogenannte Abwehrschirm
konkret bringt es geht um 200 Milliarden
Euro für Gas und strompreisbremse sowie
um die Rettung von Gasversorgern
ja dass der sogenannte doppelwumms um
den es heute aber nur indirekt gehen
sollen Nicole wir haben das gesehen
drittes Entlastungspaket viele viele
Punkte über welche was ist bisher
bekannt wurde denn am längsten und
Videos angesprochen hast auch am
hitzigsten vielleicht diskutiert wie wir
hören hat das Thema Wohngeld für
ordentlich Zoff gesorgt eben in der
großen Runde was kein Wunder ist denn
erstens soll der Kreis derer die
Wohngeld erhalten dürfen erweitert
werden und zwar wesentlich von der Zeit
ungefähr 600.000 Menschen auf rund zwei
Millionen Menschen und zum anderen
fordern die Länder das anders als jetzt
nicht mehr zur einen Hälfte sie und zur
anderen Hälfte der Bund das Wohngeld
finanzieren sondern der Bund komplett
und da ist zu hören stellt sich der
Kanzler Olaf Scholz quer
jetzt habe ich schon die ersten zwei
Fragen einfach ganz unhöflich an Dich
gestellt falls ihr natürlich die
Userinnen und User noch weitere Fragen
gehabt zu den Themen stellt ihr uns
gerne da ist die Adresse per Mail an ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de oder einfach direkt in
die Chats und ja Nicole und ich
versuchen dann natürlich so viele
Antworten wie möglich drauf zu finden
Nicole du hast auch angesprochen dass zu
hören ist dass ich da Olaf Scholz
womöglich quer stellt und womöglich dann
ein bisschen weiter auf die Bremse tritt
es ist ja in den vergangenen Wochen
immer wieder auch zu hören gewesen dass
man sich fragt wann sagt denn jetzt der
Kanzler auch mal etwas Konkretes jetzt
deutet es darauf hin dass auch da wieder
eher Tempo rausgenommen wird hast du da
vielleicht eine erste Erklärung für uns
ja und zwar gibt es ein ganz ganz großes
Fragezeichen das über einer ziemlich
großen Summe schwebt nämlich den 200
Milliarden diesem Schirm den Kanzler
Scholz und Robert Habeck
Wirtschaftsminister sowie Finanzminister
Christian Lindner vergangene Woche in
Aussicht gestellt haben nicht
vorgestellt haben und das ist der
Knackpunkt es gibt eine Kommission die
soll sich jetzt darüber Gedanken machen
bzw ist schon dabei immerhin wie dieser
Schirm aussehen soll ganz konkret wie
die gaspreisbremse aussehen soll auf die
jetzt nicht nur die Politik hofft nicht
nur die Wahlkämpfer hoffen sondern auch
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger natürlich
hoffen diese Kommission war erst in
Aussicht gestellt worden sollte Ende
Oktober erste Ideen vorstellen
Ergebnisse vorstellen jetzt hat heute
Robert Habeck in einer Pressekonferenz
gesagt naja das müssen schon anfangen
Oktober geschehen da wird jetzt also
ordentlich Druck gemacht wie zu hören
ist soll das kommende Woche passieren
also schneller als erst geplant aber
dann doch ein bisschen zu langsam um
heute mit konkreten Zahlen hantieren zu
können und das war ganz interessant als
die drei vergangene Woche eben diese
gaspreisbremse bzw die Idee vorgestellt
haben davon da wurde erst Olaf Scholz
von einem Journalisten auf der
anschließenden Pressekonferenz gefragt
was das denn jetzt eigentlich bedeutet
für die Länder ob die Länder sich von
diesen bis zu 200 Milliarden Euro auch
was abzapfen könnten und da hat Olaf
Scholz versucht so ein bisschen
auszuweichen Christian Lindner wurde
dann deutlicher und sagte naja dadurch
dass wir ja damit den Gaspreis Deckeln
bis zu einer bestimmten Menge bedeutet
das zum Beispiel ja auch für
Krankenhäuser für die die Länder ja
zuständig sind dass sich deren Ausgaben
verringern das heißt indirekt haben die
Länder ja auch was von diesen 200
Milliarden Euro
wir sind da damit aber auch gesagt hat
und es hatte auch deutlich ausgesprochen
war aber es wird nicht direkt den
Zugriff der Länder auf diesen Pott geben
und Lindner wurde heute morgen bei uns
im ZDF im Morgenmagazin auch noch sehr
viel deutlicher und sagte relativ
unverblümt dass jetzt auch mal gut sein
müsse mit Forderungen der Länder die
Länder hätten durch die Inflation zum
Beispiel Mehreinnahmen zu verbuchen und
der Bund würde sich immer weiter in neue
Verbindlichkeiten hineinbegeben da
müsste dann auch irgendwann mal Schluss
sein mit den Forderungen also da ist
viel Konfliktpotenzial schon im Vorfeld
ganz offensichtlich zu sehen gewesen du
sprichst Christian Lindner und den
Bundesfinanzminister an und auch das
Spiel zwischen Bund und Land oder Bund
und Länder die verschiedenen Forderungen
die verschiedenen Aussagen die im
Vorfeld getätigt werden und wir haben
den Ton von Christian Lindner und auch
den von Hendrik wüst dem NRW
Ministerpräsidenten vorliegen und hören
mal gemeinsam rein wenn der Bund von den
Ländern 19 Milliarden Euro haben möchte
um von ihm ins Schaufenster gestellte
Entlastungspaket mitzubezahlen von den
Kommunen immerhin noch drei Milliarden
Euro da wird man schon darüber sprechen
müssen es kann auch nicht sein dass wenn
ich das in aller Höflichkeit zu sagen
darf Länder einfach Haushaltsüberschüsse
erzielen und der Bund ist in den tiefen
roten Zahlen und muss Krisenmanagement
machen
so da haben wir beide noch mal ganz klar
im Ton gehört Nicole wie sind die
Aussagen und auch die ja sozusagen Art
und Weise zu Bewerten von beiden genau
habe ich ja eben schon gesagt also der
sagt einfach
jetzt muss man gut sein und macht ihr
doch mal Kassensturz und dann machen wir
mal Kassensturz und Hendrik wüst der
eine andere Sprache spricht der anders
Auftritt als zum Beispiel Lindner hat
finde ich in dem O-Ton den wir gerade
gehört haben eine sehr interessante
Wortwahl
hören lassen nämlich er Speicher von dem
Rettungspaket dass der Bund ist
Schaufenster gestellt hat das heißt ja
nichts anderes als
man brüstet sich jetzt man demonstriert
Handlungsfähigkeit man
wirbt für das eigene Handeln und stellt
sehr
optimistisch stimmte Aktionen in
Aussicht das heißt man versucht gute
Politik zu machen und mit Mann ist der
Bund gemeint und wir die Länder dürfen
dann einfach zahlen also dieses
verordnete das ist ein großer
Streitpunkt es geht also nicht nur
natürlich auch um konkrete Summen wir
haben es ja gerade gehört 19 Milliarden
für die Länder das kein Pappenstiel wenn
es um das dritte Rettungspaket alleine
geht aber es geht auch um den Stil also
das Empfinden der Länder ist der Bund
stellt sich hin macht sich breit gibt
eine Pressekonferenz und glänzt damit
und wir werden gar nicht gefragt sondern
wir haben dann nur das zu machen was
sich der Bund für uns mit ausgerechnet
hat das schafft natürlich auch Zwist
ja absolut der den hast Du angesprochen
der geht zum einen darum um eben den
angekündigten doppelwumms vor gut einer
Woche die 200 Milliarden dass die eine
Seite um die es heute gehen soll die
anderen natürlich die konkreten Punkte
die inhaltlichen Punkte des dritten
Entlastungspaket das haben wir
festgehalten und du hast auch gerade
angesprochen dass es ein ein Swiss
zwischen der Länderseite und der Bund
Seite ist und wir können vielleicht auch
mal gemeinsam drauf schauen auf auf
Twitter sozusagen hier habe ich das
Vorliegen da hat Markus Söder getwittert
da sehen wir einmal Daniel Günther in
der mit äh rechts und in der Mitte ist
Hendrik wüst und links eben Markus Söder
und er hat dazu geschrieben drei
Ministerpräsidenten der Union gemeinsam
durch die Krise für eine schnelle und
eine
unbürokratische gaspreisbremse
Nicole Markus Söder hat auch im Vorfeld
angekündigt sein Zitat ich zitiere das
jetzt mal das war aus dem Doppel Wumms
darf kein Würmchen werden so jetzt ist
das wenig Inhalt natürlich eine
plakative Formulierung aber warum genau
kommt diese 200 Milliarden heute Euro
heute auch immer wieder in diesen
Statement so konkret vor
zweierlei Gründe der konkrete ist ich
habe das eben kurz angerissen Jamal
natürlich kommt das auch den Ländern
zugute das diese Karte spielen vor allem
die ampelparteien ist ja klar SPD Grüne
und FDP die ihre Politik verteidigen ich
habe eben das Beispiel genannt sinken
die Energiepreise sinken natürlich auch
die Energiepreise
beziehungsweise explodieren sie nicht
weiter für Krankenhäuser zum Beispiel
das war ein großes Thema in den
vergangenen Tagen wie die Krankenhäuser
überhaupt noch arbeitsfähig bleiben
können wenn die Kosten auch für sie
explodieren dass das eine die andere
Seite ist natürlich wird hier knallhart
Politik gemacht die
unionsministerpräsidenten
sind unions Politiker und damit
Opposition
und versuchen natürlich auch die
ampelparteien vor sich herzutreiben ich
habe es eben schon erwähnt in
Niedersachsen wird am Beitrag gewählt
kommendes Jahr wird aber auch zum
Beispiel in Bayern gewählt und Markus
Söder möchte natürlich dort
wiedergewählt werden und er wäre kein
Bayer wenn er nicht doch noch insgeheim
von der absoluten Mehrheit Träumen würde
das heißt es geht immer auch darum
Politik auf die eigene Rechnung zu
machen das ist im übrigen auch sehr
interessant zu beobachten wir haben ja
eben einen Ausschnitt gesehen von
Christian Lindner aus dem Morgenmagazin
heute das Interview war ja länger als
diesen Schnipsel den wir eben gesehen
haben
Lindner hat er gesprochen als
Bundesfinanzminister aber eben ganz klar
identifizieren können es ging darum was
macht der Bund was wollen die Länder da
ist er Bestandteil des Bundes der
Bundesregierung der ampelregierung in
diesem Interview genauso in der
Pressekonferenz vergangene Woche
gemeinsam mit Scholz und gemeinsam mit
Harbeck hat Lindner es nicht
lassen können nochmal seine Position und
damit rede ich jetzt vom
FDP-Vorsitzenden die seiner Partei zu
untermauern dass die Atomkraft viel
stärker als jetzt nach mehreren
Kompromissen vor allem ja mit den Grünen
genutzt werden muss und das ist
natürlich auch Wahlkampf
ja du sprichst es an also auch
Parteipolitik in Zeiten wo Bürgerinnen
und Bürger aber natürlich irgendwie
konkrete Antworten wollen und vor allen
Dingen antworten wollen wie werden wir
entlastet und wer zahlt das ganze ich
habe die Kommentare im Blick Mister
screwi schreibt auf Youtube wir brauchen
jetzt keine almode sondern wirklich eine
konkrete Lösung der Energieprobleme in
die uns auch die Ampel gebracht hat und
ein zweiter Kommentar vielleicht auch
noch hinterher von kinokitai er findet
zynisch dass die Schuldenbremse mit der
Rücksichtnahme auf kommende Generation
gerechtfertigt wird ja und warum man
dann nicht in Infrastruktur und
Klimaschutz investiert Nicole kannst du
den Frust oder ja sozusagen auch die
Kritik die dazu lesen ist verstehen
naja also natürlich kann man das
verstehen alle machen sich Sorgen nicht
nur weil die Preise explodieren sondern
sicherlich auch weil ja noch gar keine
Zahlen auf dem Tisch liegen es sind eine
Unsicherheit wird ja dadurch noch
verstärkt dass man wirklich nichts
handfestes hat gar nichts handfestes
dass das eine und da Stichwort
Schuldenbremse ist ja eben gefallen auch
das gehört zu dieser Debatte ganz klar
dazu dieser bis zu 200 Milliarden große
Fonds der da jetzt wieder aufgelegt wird
der eigentlich aus corona-zeiten noch
stammt
das ist ein der Versuch wir werden sehen
ob er glückt
trotz des FDP Versprechens da haben wir
es wieder Parteipolitik die
Schuldenbremse ab 2023 wieder
einzuhalten sehr viel Geld locker zu
machen auch für Wählerinnen und Wähler
das heißt es lässt sich nie voneinander
lösen und das merken die Leute natürlich
auch das merken die Leute natürlich auch
jetzt die eine Frage sollte man jetzt in
so einer Situation Schulden aufnehmen
oder nicht das ist
das nimmt ja Dimensionen an Inflation
drohende Rezession
der vermag ich mir kein Urteil zu
erlauben ob es möglich wäre keine
Schulden aufzunehmen aber die
Schuldenbremse die spielt eine zentrale
Rolle in dieser ganzen Diskussion und da
eben auch wieder die weit zum Teil weit
auseinander liegenden Positionen
einerseits der FDP die dafür einsteht
angetreten ist im Bundestagswahlkampf
die Schuldenbremse wieder einzuhalten
und auf der anderen Seite zum Beispiel
die SPD aus der sich die in den
vergangenen Tagen Wochen mehren die
sagen das ist hier eine historisch
einmalige Situation wir müssen jetzt mit
der Schuldenbremse mal wieder lockerer
umgehen es geht einfach nicht anders
dann gehen wir vielleicht noch mal ganz
kurz weg auch von den von den Parteien
und gehen noch mal auf die inhaltlichen
Punkte um dies heute auch gehen soll du
hast angesprochen dass es wohl beim
Wohngeld bei der Diskussion darüber am
heftigsten geknirscht hat dass da
womöglich auch immer oder wir schauen da
gemeinsam auch auf die die Livebilder
bei der Pressekonferenz da da tut sich
im Moment immer noch nichts das heißt da
wird womöglich immer noch debattiert und
irgendwie noch um Einigungen oder
Formulierungen gerungen was ja auch
viele interessiert vielleicht haben wir
da ja auch schon Informationen ist
möglicher Nachfolger des 9-euro-tickets
ist da schon irgendwas bekannt worüber
und wie darüber diskutiert wurde heute
naja das ist auch noch mal das was
Hendrik wüst NRW Ministerpräsident aus
der CDU meint mit ins Schaufenster
stellen die der Bund hat
angeboten zusätzlich eineinhalb
Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung zu stellen
um Nachfolge Modelle in den einzelnen
Ländern zu finden für das berühmte 9
euro-ticket wenn die Länder sich auch
mit derselben Summe noch mal beteiligen
also auch noch mal eineinhalb Milliarden
obendrauf legen und das ist natürlich
tatsächlich ein schwieriger move
einerseits Wissen weiß das Kabinett weiß
die Ampel natürlich wie populär das
nordeuroticket war die Zahlen sprechen
ja eine komplett deutliche Sprache plus
der Vorteil dass man dieses sich
zwischen unterschiedlichen
Netzen zwischen unterschiedlichen
Tarifbereichen nicht mehr zurechtfinden
musste und also erstmal quasi pro
Seminar wo bin ich eigentlich was kostet
mich hier in der Bahnfahrt belegen
musste sobald man mal das Bundesland
gewechselt hat und haben dann drauf
gesetzt auch damit machen wir uns
beliebt wenn wir uns bereit erklären wir
sind im Boot wir machen damit an uns
soll es nicht scheitern und gleichzeitig
eben den Ländern noch mal zusätzlich
anderthalb Milliarden Euro aufs Auge
drücken das hat man in manchen
Bundesländern tatsächlich als ein
vergiftetes Geschenk empfunden und da
sagen jetzt die Länder eben auch das
reicht nicht da muss mehr kommen das
können wir alleine so nicht schultern
liebe Nicole ich habe gerade die Info
aus der Regie bekommen dass die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz jetzt wohl
durch ist und dass ich die Beteiligten
auf ihre Statements vorbereiten
vielleicht kannst du uns dann einen
kleinen Einblick geben wie läuft denn
dann solche Prozesse dann danach ab bis
es dann eben auf das Podium geht
oh da erwischt du mich auf dem kalten
Fuß ich nehme mal an dass ich jeder der
drei die da gleich sitzen werden noch
mal für sich durchliest was haben wir da
beschlossen womit sehe ich am besten aus
da sind sie schon
und dann versucht man eben diesen
Balanceakt den ich eben schon den ich
eben schon einmal angesprochen habe
einerseits geeint zu wirken es geht ja
um was es ist ja eine ernste Lage und
andererseits aber vor allem im Falle von
Stefan weil der am Montag am Sonntag
wieder Ministerpräsident werden will
irgendwie zu glänzen ohne Zweifel zu
lassen an seinem Teamgeist der Prozess
der Vorbereitung der scheint jetzt
abgeschlossen die drei Herren haben
Platz genommen und dann wollen wir hören
was es vielleicht für konkrete Antworten
gibt
Scholz den neuen Vorsitzenden der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
Niedersachsens MP Stefan weil und den
bisherigen Vorsitzender
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
Niedersachsens landesschef Hendrik wüst
was habe ich gesagt besser wäre noch
eine besser wäre Nordrhein-Westfalen
höre ich gerade also noch einmal und
auch der nordrhein-westfälischen
Ministerpräsident ist hier darüber freue
ich mich ganz besonders und noch mehr
freue ich mich dass der Bundeskanzler
beginnen wird
meine Damen und Herren wir haben hier
haben heute sehr gut konstruktiv und
auch relativ zügig miteinander beraten
über die großen Herausforderungen von
denen unser Land steht und was deswegen
zu tun ist wir alle wissen dass der
russische Angriffskrieg nicht nur
furchtbare Konsequenzen für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger der Ukraine hat
dass er mit furchtbaren Zerstörungen
verbunden ist was Städte Dörfer und
Infrastruktur des Landes betrifft dass
viele Menschen gestorben sind in der
Ukraine und jeden Tag weiter sterben
sondern wir wissen dieser Krieg hat auch
Konsequenzen für uns alle in Europa
weltweit sogar aber eben auch in
Deutschland
und deshalb war es sehr wichtig dass wir
sehr früh angefangen haben uns auf diese
Konsequenzen vorzubereiten etwas dafür
zu tun dass die
Energieversorgungssicherheit in
Deutschland gewährleistet bleibt und das
haben wir gemacht mit weitreichenden
Entscheidungen seit Beginn diesen Jahres
die dazu beigetragen haben dass wir
heute sagen können wir werden die
Energieversorgungssicherheit für
Deutschland wohl gewährleisten können
wir haben dazu beigetragen dass wir
neue importmöglichkeiten größer nutzen
und in westeuropäischen Häfen in
Niederlanden Belgien und Frankreichs wir
bauen neue importmöglichkeiten an den
norddeutschen Küsten mit neuen
lng-terminals in Wilhelmshaven in Stade
in Brunsbüttel und in Lubmin an der
Ostsee wir haben die Speicher voll
gemacht es sind heute über 92 Prozent
Füllstand zu vermelden wir sorgen dafür
dass Kohlekraftwerke nicht vom Netz
gehen und diejenigen die sich im
Einsatzreserve befunden haben wieder
Strom produzieren mit Kohle wir nutzen
die Möglichkeiten der Süddeutschen
Atomkraftwerke Anfang des Jahres für die
Stromproduktion und wir haben dafür
gesorgt dass alle Unternehmen die dazu
die Möglichkeit haben schnell und
unbürokratisch umsteigen können von Gas
auf die Nutzung von Öl oder Kohle um
ihre
energieversorgungsfragestellung und ihre
produktionsfragestellung zu lösen das
alles hat zu diesem Zustand geführt dass
wir heute sagen können wir werden wohl
die Energieversorgungssicherheit
gewährleisten können obwohl es kein Gas
mehr gibt das aus Russland nach
Deutschland kommt über die Pipelines und
obwohl wir jetzt sogar ganz aktuell von
den dramatischen Zerstörungen an einigen
der pipels in der Ostsee gehört haben
aber neben der Frage der Sicherheit der
Versorgung stellt sich die Frage der
Preise der Inflation der Energiepreise
gerade was Strom und Gas und
Wärmeleistung betrifft und das ist ganz
klar für uns alle und gilt für die
Bundesregierung genauso für die wie für
die 16 Länder die Preise müssen runter
die Preise für Strom die Preise für Gas
können nicht da bleiben wo sie heute
sind das gilt im internationalen Maßstab
deshalb sprechen wir in der Europäischen
Union mit vielen anderen darüber wie wir
dafür sorgen können dass die heute
überhöhten Preise wieder auf ein
normales Niveau sinken wir stellen fest
auch der Gaspreis ist zuletzt wieder
gesunken aber das ist immer noch ein
viel zu hoher Preis und wir wollen dass
es weiter nach unten geht das wird die
eine Aufgabe sein aber darüber hinaus
müssen wir so lange das noch nicht der
Fall ist alles dazu beitragen dass die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dass die
Arbeitnehmern und Arbeitnehmer dass die
Familien dass die Renten und Rentner die
Studierenden alle diejenigen die
Wärmeleistungen die Stromleistungen in
Anspruch nehmen Ihre Rechnung bezahlen
können das ist nämlich angesichts der
gegenwärtig verzeiht zu verzeichnen
Preissteigerung nicht für alle
gewährleistet und darum haben wir uns
entschlossen mit zwei großen Bremsen
dazu beizutragen dass die Preise
runtergehen mit der strompreisbremse die
wir schon lange auf den Weg gebracht
haben an der wir hart arbeiten und für
die jetzt die Europäische Union bei den
Beratungen des energierats am Freitag
grünes Licht gegeben hat wir können also
übermäßige zufallsgewinne abschöpfen und
können Sie dazu benutzen die Strompreise
für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger und für
die Unternehmen nach unten zu senken und
dazu gehört der gaspreisdeckel den wir
auf den Weg bringen und der auch mit
erheblichen Mitteln dazu beitragen soll
dass die Gaspreise die Wärmepreise
wieder runtergehen und wir das so lange
es nicht auf dem internationalen
Gasmarkt der Fall ist mit den
Möglichkeiten der Förderung tun die wir
hier in Deutschland haben wir haben zur
Finanzierung dieser Aufgabe und dieser
Aufgaben den Wirtschafts- und so
Stabilisierungsfonds neu belebt und
werden ihn mit 200 Milliarden Euro
ausstatten und diese 200 Milliarden Euro
sollen dazu beitragen dass all das
gelingt dass die Gaspreise die
Wärmepreise nach unten gehen erheblich
für die Unternehmen und für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dass die
Strompreise nach unten gehen können auch
durch Mittel der aus diesem Zusammenhang
stammen wir werden aus dem die
Unternehmen unterstütz Menschen die
Verträge geschlossen haben über
gastlieferungen die nicht eingehalten
werden seitens Russland und die sich
jetzt schnell neu am Markt anderswo
eindecken müssen und deshalb viel höher
einkaufen müssen als sie später liefern
können und das alles zusammen werden wir
Schultern angesichts der großen
Dimensionen dieses 200 Milliarden Pakets
das für dieses Jahr das nächste Jahr und
das übernächste Jahr gedacht ist wir
sind sehr froh dass das jetzt eine
Maßnahme ist die ergriffen werden kann
und die ihre dramatische Wirkung
zugunsten der Bürgerinnen und Bürger und
zugunsten der Unternehmen zur Sicherung
von Arbeitsplätzen jetzt entfalten kann
natürlich bedeutet das dass wir
diese 200 Milliarden Entlastung
zusätzlich organisieren zu denen die mit
den drei entlastungspaketen über die
sich die Bundesregierung schon
verständigt hat und die die in der
Gesetzgebung des Bundestages schon waren
oder sein werden noch dazukommt es sind
drei entlastungspakete von zusammen 95
Milliarden Euro wenn man alle drei alles
zusammenfasst die 200 Milliarden den wir
jetzt mit dem Wirtschafts- und
Stabilisierungsfonds bereitstellen zu
Entlastung der Strom- und Gaspreise mit
den entlastungspaketen 12 und 3 die
zusammen 95 Milliarden ausmachen reden
wir hier von 295 Milliarden Euro
der Bund wird davon knapp 240 250
Milliarden Euro auf seine Kappe nehmen
und finanzieren das ist die große
Aufgabe die wir schultern müssen und
selbstverständlich freuen wir uns dass
wir mit den Ländern darüber jetzt sehr
konstruktiv sprechen können wie wir die
Dinge die hier zu tun sind gemeinsam
voranbringen können das betrifft auch
die konkrete Ausgestaltung der
Entlastungsmaßnahmen mit dem Strom und
gaspreisbremsen aber das gilt natürlich
auch für die entlastungspakete die die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger unmittelbar
entlasten sollen die dafür sorgen dass
mehr Netto vom brutto-nacht bleibt in
Portemonnaie dass es viel Unterstützung
gibt für diejenigen die Unterstützung
brauchen da gibt es noch Diskussionen
wie das im Einzelnen geschultert werden
kann die zwischen Bund und Ländern nicht
abgeschlossen sind aber ich habe den
Eindruck dass wir dafür ein sehr
konstruktiven Pfad unterwegs sind und
uns auch miteinander über diese Aufgabe
verständigen werden auch die Länder
haben sehr genau gesehen wie groß der
Beitrag des Bundes in jedem Fall sein
wird mit 240 und 250 Milliarden Euro von
den insgesamt 295 Milliarden die da als
Entlastung für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger fließen
dazu gehören auch Aufgaben die nicht
unmittelbar aus diesem Krieg alle Folgen
aber zumindest teilweise wie zum
Beispiel die Frage der
Kosten für Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine
aber auch aus anderen Ländern wir sind
miteinander verabredet dass wir bis zum
Ende des Jahres darüber eine
Verständigung herbeiführen wie der Bund
die Länder bei der Finanzierung ihrer
Aufgaben unterstützen kann und dazu sind
wir auch bereit und das ist auch
festgelegt miteinander dass wir das tun
werden insgesamt also sehr viel was
jetzt unsere Gemeinschaft auf ihre
starken Schultern nehmen kann damit
nicht die einzelnen Bürgern und Bürger
der einzelne Handwerksbetrieb das
einzelne Unternehmen das alleine tun
muss was sicherlich zu viel wäre und
deshalb bin ich froh dass ein solcher
Schulterschluss der ja dazu gehört wenn
man was auf die eigene Schulter nimmt
auch gelingt zwischen Bund und Ländern
das ist jedenfalls meine zuversichtliche
Zusammenfassung des heutigen Gesprächs
ich will am Schluss nicht vergessen mich
zu bedanken bei Herrn wüst für die gute
Kooperation als
Chef der ministerpräsidentinnen und
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz in der
letzten Zeit zusammen mit Frau giffer
ich bedanke mich bei Ihnen beiden für
das was sie da in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten an guter Zusammenarbeit möglich
gemacht haben ich freue mich auf die
gute Zusammenarbeit mit Stefan weil und
mit ihnen beiden dann in neuer
Zusammensetzung ich glaube das ist eine
Situation in unserem Land in der eine
freundschaftliche Kooperation zwischen
Bund und Ländern ist das ist was die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger wollen und das
werden sie von uns auch bekommen
meine Damen und Herren auch von mir
einen guten Abend
das waren das kann man sagen sehr
konstruktive Beratung und zwar
vor dem Hintergrund einer Situation die
wir alle miteinander als ernst ansehen
es ist in vielen Beiträgen heute zum
Ausdruck gekommen wie groß im Einzelnen
die Not vom Bürgerinnen und Bürgern ist
von Unternehmen von Menschen die um
ihren Arbeitsplatz fürchten dass all
dies Themen sind die ja wirklich auch an
den Nerv von vielen Menschen rühren und
wir sind uns auch miteinander bewusst
dass die klare Erwartung von Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern darin besteht dass die
Politik in dieser Hinsicht nicht in
erster Linie sich streitet sondern dass
wir sehr schnell auch gemeinsam zu
Entscheidungen gelangen das teile ich
ausdrücklich
ist es übrigens auch eine Erwartung die
ich derzeit ja aus besonderem Anlass
tagtäglich in der Begegnung mit vielen
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern gespiegelt
bekomme und deswegen bin ich mir sehr
sicher dass ich mit diesen Empfindungen
nicht falsch liege
wir sind am letzten Donnerstag das
letzte Mal in der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
auseinandergegangen
allerdings infolge der Krankheit des
Bundeskanzlers ohne die Bundesregierung
wenige Tage später treffen wir uns
wieder ins hat sich doch etwas ganz
Wesentliches verändert das angekündigte
und ebenfalls eben vom Bundeskanzler
Scholz erläuterte 200 Milliarden
Programm ist glaube ich von allen
Beteiligten als ein großer ganz
wichtiger Schritt gewürdigt worden
man muss einfach feststellen dass das
gemessen beispielsweise an den großen
Anstrengungen die wir während der
Bankenkrise oder wegen während der
Pandemie eingegangen sind einfach noch
einmal ein weiterer großer Beweis dafür
ist dass wir ein Staat haben der aktiv
an der Seite seiner Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und auch an der Seite der
Wirtschaft steht und dass wir auf dieser
Grundlage auch noch wesentlich
effektiver werden Maßnahmen ergreifen
können als das ohne einen solchen
Schritt möglich gewesen also ich will
ausdrücklich einfach noch einmal
Dankeschön sagen ich empfinde das als
einen Durchbruch in unseren Bemühungen
die sozialen und wirtschaftlichen Folgen
der energiepreiskrise einzudämmen
gleichzeitig haben wir heute beraten zu
einem Zeitpunkt wo noch nicht die
konkreten
Entscheidungen getroffen werden können
beispielsweise weil wir noch nicht
wissen wie wird genau die
energiepreisbremse die strompreisbremse
die gaspreisbremse ausschauen die
Bundesregierung hat hierzu bekanntlich
eine Kommission von Expertinnen und
Experten eingesetzt die unter Hochdruck
arbeitet aber jedenfalls heute noch
keine Ergebnisse hatte und es wird für
alle verständlich sein dass wir unter
diesen Bedingungen tatsächlich diese
Grundlagen brauchen um bewerten zu
können an welchen Stellen können wir so
schon sagen damit haben wir das notwend
werden wir das notwendige erreichen wo
muss man noch nachsteuern aber womöglich
auch feststellen muss dass bestimmte
Dinge dann nicht mehr notwendig sind
deswegen haben wir heute das
genutzt um noch einmal sehr gründlich
die anstehenden Themen im Einzelnen
durchzusprechen und insbesondere auch
miteinander zu vereinbaren dass wir sehr
schnell gute Entscheidung kommen werden
was ist da für notwendig erstens eine
Konkretisierung wie verteilt sich wir
teilen sich die 200 Milliarden und
welche Entlastungswirkung ist damit wo
verbunden und zweitens auch das ist ein
wichtiger Punkt der vom
Bundesfinanzminister plausibler Weise
dargelegt wurde wie schauen eigentlich
die steuerlichen Erwartungen aus sie
wissen das jetzt die
herbst-steuerschätzung ins Haus steht
auch das ist sicherlich etwas was wir
wissen müssen um zu sehen wie es
weitergeht gleichzeitig haben wir eine
Reihe von Themen angesprochen wo wir
noch nicht
Konsens haben aber das muss eben bis zum
Ende dann geschehen das ist zum einen
das Thema Wohngeld da vertreten die
Länder bekanntlich die Position dass
diese Kosten vom Bund doch übernommen
werden sollen wir werden künftig mit
einer Verdreifachung der Zahlen wohl zu
kalkulieren haben und gleichzeitig muss
ich sagen wir haben uns darüber gefreut
über das nochmalige sehr klare
Bekenntnis der
Bundesregierung dass man zu einem
deutlich vereinfachten Antragsverfahren
gelangen will das dass das wesentlich
praktischer angelegt sein soll das ist
meines Erachtens deswegen
außerordentlich wichtig weil viele
Menschen die eigentlich zum
Empfängerkreis dieser Sozialleistung
dann gehören würden wahrscheinlich durch
einen aufwendiges kompliziertes
Antragsverfahren eher davon abgeschreckt
würden das müssen wir vermeiden und wir
sehen dann den konkreten Vorstellungen
der Bundesregierung entgegen es gibt
weitere Themen wo wir sehen dass die
laufenden Verhandlungen noch nicht zu
Ende geführt sind aber das Geschehen
muss das gilt beispielsweise für das
Thema ÖPNV Nachfolgemodell 9 Euro Ticket
aber auch gleichzeitig Fortsetzung der
Regionalisierungsmittel dahinter steht
um es einfach nochmal zu erläutern dass
das 9 euro-ticket insbesondere in den
Ballungsräumen eine ganz erhebliche
Erleichterung ist aber in vielen
ländlichen Räumen da wo das ÖPNV-Angebot
schlecht ist natürlich von den
Bürgerinnen und längst nicht so als
Entlastung wahrgenommen wird wie eine
Verbesserung des Angebots einfach ein
Thema an dem wir weiter miteinander
arbeiten müssen um zu einer Einigung zu
gelangen und dann gibt es Bereiche wo
die Länder sich in besonderer Weise auch
als Sachwalter kommunaler Interessen
vertreten wenn ich beispielsweise etwa
an die Situation von Krankenhäusern
denke und auch die kommunale
Energiewirtschaft da sehen wir das große
Schwierigkeiten auf dieser Unternehmen
zukommen die lassen sich noch nicht
abschließend beziffern weil auch dort
natürlich die energiepreisbremse
Auswirkungen haben wird aber mutmaßlich
werden wir auch in dieser Hinsicht noch
zu diskutieren haben was geschehen muss
um beispielsweise die Krankenhäuser in
sicheres wirtschaftliches Fahrwasser zu
bringen also alles in allem aus meiner
Sicht gut gute Gespräche die sich heute
noch nicht in die ganz konkreten
Ergebnisse um und haben unmünzen lassen
aber die Grundlage dafür gelegt haben
dass das relativ schnell geschehen soll
was heißt das wir werden in etwas mehr
als zwei Wochen in Hannover die
nächste
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz haben das
ist eigentlich eine ohne Bundesregierung
aber auf meine Bitte hin hat der
Bundeskanzler zugestimmt dass dann ein
qualifizierter Zwischenbericht durch die
Bundesregierung gegeben wird das wird
uns schon mal weiterhelfen uns weiter an
eine schnelle Entscheidung dann
heranzuarbeiten dann ist die
Steuerschätzung schnell sehr schnell und
wir hoffen dass wir Ende des Monats
Anfang des nächsten Monats dann wirklich
unter all das ein finalen Strich machen
können denn wir sind uns gemeinsam
bewusst dass Bürgerinnen und Bürger vor
einigen schnell Klarheit haben wollen
das gilt auch für viele Unternehmen je
schneller diese Klarheit kommt desto
besser und dass das eine ganz
wesentliche Entscheidung ist die
sicherlich auch die Einstellung von
vielen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
maßgeblich beeinflussen wird dessen sind
wir uns bewusst ich will sagen dass ich
das heute als eine wesentliche
Zwischenetappe empfunden habe dass das
sinnvoll gewesen ist was wir hier
miteinander diskutiert haben und die
Grundlage dafür bieten wird dass wir
demnächst dann hoffentlich insgesamt mit
einem Konzept aufwarten können dass die
Erwartung von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
von Wirtschaft erfüllt das finanzierbar
ist und dass uns gleichzeitig die
Gewissheit gibt die energiepreiskrise
gemeinsam in den Griff zu kriegen
herzlichen Dank
ja meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
die Herausforderung dieses Herbstes und
Winters sind groß und vielfältig die
Menschen erwarten zu Recht von uns klare
und verlässliche Lösungen um gut durch
diese Zeit zu kommen in dieser Krise ist
zu meiner feste Überzeugungen nationalen
Einheit notwendig zwischen Bund Ländern
und Kommunen deswegen ist es richtig und
wichtig dass wir heute
zusammengekommen sind die Länder sind
nach reiflicher Vorbereitung in der
letzten Woche und auch heute
konstruktiv und mit ausgestreckter Hand
in diese Gespräche gegangen der Kollege
weil hat ja die offenen Fragen und
dissense gerade beschrieben deswegen
liegt das auch ganz ehrlich sagen die
Bundesregierung hat heute trotz der
konstruktiven Einstellung der Länder
kaum Kompromissbereitschaft in ganz
wesentlichen Fragen erkennen lassen ich
kann verstehen wenn darüber viele
Menschen enttäuscht sind weil sie etwas
anderes erwartet haben wir sind heute
nur ganz wenige Schritte
vorangekommen und noch heißt nicht am
Ziel was ist jetzt eine ehrliche
Feststellung und aus Sicht vieler Länder
ist das im Ergebnis einfach zu wenig
immerhin es gibt jetzt einen weiteren
Fahrplan aber es bestehen eben auch noch
eine ganze Menge offener Fragen die vor
allen Dingen auch die Bundesregierung
beantworten muss für die Länder ist beim
Thema energiepreisbremse wichtig dass
wir jetzt Klarheit und Tempo kriegen
Menschen wollen schnell und wollen
verbindlich wissen wie hoch die
Entlastung für Sie persönlich konkret
ausfallen und unsere Unternehmen
brauchen Klarheit bei den Energiekosten
um Angebote schreiben zu können und
planen zu können um disponieren zu
können nur so bleiben Arbeitsplätze in
dieser schwierigen Zeit sicher viele
Betriebe fragen sich wie Sie jetzt durch
die nächsten Monate durchkommen wollen
da zählt jeder Tag die Heizsaison hat
begonnen der Bund muss jetzt
Planungssicherheit schaffen für die
Menschen für Unternehmen und für die nun
will das ehrlich sagen wir hätten uns
deshalb gewünscht dass wir heute etwas
mehr erfahren über die Wirkung der
energiepreisbremse wenn schon nicht den
letzten Cent betragt und wenigstens
einen Korridor erst wenn das klar ist
wenn wir da konkretere Informationen
haben kann man verlässlich beurteilen ob
das Gesamtpaket an Entlastung auch
wirklich sitzt den Ländern ist wichtig
dass wir zielgenau entlasten die
Menschen brauchen jetzt soziale
Sicherheit und das ist auch eine Frage
wie wir über Herbst und Winter den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt
gewährleisten wir müssen deshalb
diejenigen entlasten die ist wirklich in
dieser Zeit brauchen untere mittlere
Einkommen kleine mittlere Unternehmen
insbesondere energieintensive
Unternehmen aus meiner Sicht auch
Pendlerinnen und Pendler die Länder
haben deshalb durchgesetzt dass der Bund
und die Länder über spezifische
Entlastung in diesem Sinne sprechen
sobald der Bund sein Konzept zur
energiepreisbremse vorgelegt hat mir ist
wichtig dass wir auch die Lage der
Kommunen berücksichtigen für die
Energieversorgung spielen da die
Stadtwerke vor Ort eine ganz ganz
wesentliche Rolle da ist unser Anliegen
als Länder das ist ein Schutzschirm für
die Stadtwerke geben muss wir müssen
auch weitere kommunale Belange
berücksichtigen das Thema Krankenhäuser
ist heute mehrfach angesprochen worden
mit sehr sehr hohen Kosten durch die
Energiepreise da kann man die einfach
sagen wie ein Büros wir gehen mal runter
auf 19 Grad das ganz offensichtlich dass
das nicht geht und Universitätskliniken
Pflegeeinrichtungen die komplette
soziale Infrastruktur bei der
Finanzierung sind die Länder bereit mit
zu tun aber wir wollen natürlich eine
faire Lastenteilung die es den Kommunen
und den Ländern ermöglicht die Dinge die
sie in eigener Verantwortung zu tun
haben auch am Ende umzusetzen wenn ich
mal schaue auf den ganzen
Bildungsbereich von der Kita bis zur Uni
oder Berufsschule wir werden die doch
nicht wieder zu machen wollen
zwei Jahren Pandemie das wird
Verantwortung von Kommunen und Ländern
sein das was über die energiepreisbremse
nicht abgefangen und wird dann zu
gewährleisten darum geht es wenn wir
über eine Schere verlastenverteilung
sprechen in diesem Punkt ist die
Bundesregierung Ländern bisher nicht
ansatzweise ausreichend Entgegenkommen
ich will allerdings Versagen der
Bundeskanzler in Aussicht gestellt hat
das ist ein Entgegenkommen an einem
Punkt gegeben wird soweit so gut wir
sehen große Belastungen für unsere
Städte und Gemeinden steigende
Energiekosten steigende Sozialkosten
Unterbringung von Flüchtlingen
absehbarer Mehraufwand bei der
Administration des wohngelds die
Situation der Stadtwerke habe ich eben
schon genannt Kostensteigerungen im ÖPNV
aufgrund der kompletten Energiekosten
Situation deswegen sind wir uns einig
als Länder dass das Gesamtpaket 3 ein
Gesamtpaket eingebettet werden muss wir
versuchen seit Wochen dafür zu werben
dass da eben auch noch Themen sind das
Thema Mobilität da gibt es die Zusage
das ist ein aufwuchs gibt auch jenseits
der Frage einer ticketlösung Nachfolge 9
Euro Ticket noch mal sagen gerade die
Kolleginnen Kollegen parteiübergreifend
aus den Flächenländern heute noch mal
gesagt es darf nicht passieren dass wir
nachher eine Lösung für das Ticket haben
aber weil ansonsten das Geld im ÖPNV
nicht mehr da ist Takte ausdünnen müssen
oder Linien einstellen das kann man den
Leuten glaube ich nicht erklären auch da
müssen wir noch zu einer Lösung kommen
auch das war heute leider nicht möglich
da sollen jetzt die Verkehrsminister
noch einmal daran arbeiten weiterer
Herausforderung ist in diesem Herbst das
Thema Flüchtlinge
flüchtlingskosten viele viele Menschen
helfen mit einem großen Herz hier in
unserem Land aber es sieht eben auch
viele Flüchtlinge gekommen nicht nur aus
der Ukraine sondern weit darüber hinaus
wir wollen wir müssen für anständige
Unterbringung sorgen es wäre noch im
Winter mehr Menschen noch wieder aus der
Ukraine kommen das wird nicht aufhören
wenn da dahinter die Kälte die Nässe in
die Wohnungen kriecht wir wollen helfen
aber wir wollen eben auch an der Stelle
dass wir zu konkreten Umsetzung der
Zusage der Bundesregierung kommen die am
7 April gegeben wurde eine
Nachfolgelösung für die Finanzierung
dieser Fragen zu finden die Verhandlung
heute Kollege Weilands richtig gesagt
können nur ein Zwischenschritt gewesen
sein sie können kein Endpunkt sein wir
werden auch in die weiteren Gespräche
mit dem Bund mit
Verantwortungsbewusstsein und
konstruktiver Grundhaltung gehen wir
müssen zu schnellen Lösungen kommen
damit die Menschen im Herbst und Winter
Planungssicherheit haben
vielen Dank dann habe ich als erstes
Fragen der Theresa Münch von dpa in der
Mitte Sekunde Mikro kommt
gesagt die Erwartung der Bürger ist dass
es jetzt schnelle Entscheidungen gibt
glauben Sie sie haben heute die
Erwartung der Bürger enttäuscht denn der
Eindruck der jetzt entsteht aus ihrem
Treffen ist dass sie sich nicht einigen
konnten und normale Bürger werden kaum
Verständnis dafür haben dass es an so
einer Frage wie Aufteilung der
Finanzierung scheitern soll dass sie
entlastet werden und an Herrn wüst die
Frage sie haben das 200 Milliarden Euro
Paket eine Wundertüte genannt sind sie
jetzt schlauer was den Inhalt dieser
Wundertüte angeht und ist mit dem
heutigen Tag die Wahrscheinlichkeit
gestiegen dass das Ganze am Ende im
Vermittlungsausschuss ausgetragen werden
muss
nicht ganz einfach wir haben uns bereit
erklärt 250 Milliarden Euro auf die
Bundeskasse zu nehmen von 295 Milliarden
das ist eine ordentliche Summe und
darunter sind auch die 200 Milliarden zu
Entlastung bei den Energiepreisen neben
den Dingen die sich selbst aus der
strompreisbremsen Konstruktion
finanzieren deshalb werden die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger sehr schnell und
sehr genau Bescheid wissen wir die
Bundesregierung die Entlastung vornehmen
wird es ist hier schon berichtet worden
und ich wiederhole das noch mal wir
haben aus gutem Grund eine
Expertengruppe eingesetzt um die Frage
der gaspreisbremse konkret zu besprechen
die hat schon getagt die hat heute
getagt sie wird am Wochenende wieder
Tagen ich gehe davon aus dass wir
nächste Woche Ergebnisse haben zu denen
wir uns nun auch sofort verhalten werden
können und die dann auch jedem
nachrechnbar machen wie seine Entlastung
ganz konkret aussieht das ist schon
etwas das sehr gut gemacht werden muss
deshalb bin ich froh das Wissenschaftler
und Wissenschaftler dabei sind aller
Provenienz dass wir Vertreter und
Vertreter aus den relevanten Unternehmen
haben die mit ihrer Expertise dazu
beitragen dass wir eine sehr vernünftige
Lösung entwickeln und zwar großen und
kleinen Unternehmen Versorgungsbetrieben
denjenigen die im großen Maßstab Energie
produzieren und mit Energie handeln und
selbstverständlich sind auch
dort die drei Vorsitzenden Frau Grimm
und was im Jahr des Unterrichtsform die
das alles managen das ist richtig genau
die richtige Gruppe die da jetzt
zusammenkommt und die sich wirklich
schon intensiv an die Arbeit gemacht hat
und wenn man sagt nächste Woche können
wir wohl die ersten Ergebnisse sehen
zudem wenn er auch sagen können wie wir
das machen werden dass wir das umsetzen
werden ist das glaube ich genau das was
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger erwarten die
wollen ja nicht an hin und her die
wollen eine Lösung die sitzt und die
tatsächlich dazu führt dass sie nicht
mehr mit Magenbeschwerden auf ihre
Rechnung gucken müssen die jetzt von den
Versorgungsunternehmen kommt sondern
dass sie wissen das geht runter und
selbst wer jetzt eine hohe Rechnung hat
meist schon das wird wieder runtergehen
und das ist genau das was wir mit
immerhin 200 Milliarden tun was
gaspreisbremse und Zuschüsse zur
strompreisbremse betrifft und das kommt
dann noch dazu was aus den
entlastungspaketen erwächst ich bin ganz
froh übrigens auch über die
konstruktiven Beratung und den
freundlichen Ton
eine Wundertüte ist ja erstmal was was
positives und die Anerkennung für die
sie Dimension des Paketes haben die
Länder auch zum Ausdruck gebracht was
drin steckt sind wir heute nicht
schlauer geworden daran hat sich heute
nichts geändert
vielen Dank Herr Bundeskanzler sie
werden entschuldigen dass man den
Eindruck hat nach den Ausführungen den
drei Ausführungen hier das sie nicht in
der gleichen in der gleichen Sitzung
eben waren zumindest mit Herrn wüst der
sehr klare Kritik geäußert hat dass es
keinerlei Entgegenkommen von Seiten der
Bundesregierung gegeben habe was sagen
sie zu dieser Kritik und warum ist das
so dass man sich in den Streitfragen
bisher in keiner der Streitfragen bisher
einigen konnte und derweil teilen sie
eigentlich die Kritik von Herrn wüst
oder haben Sie einfach eine andere
Einschätzung von dem was heute erreicht
werden konnte vielen Dank
das war heute ich will das noch mal
wiederholen eine sehr konstruktive
Beratung und die Länder haben auch sehr
genau verstanden an welche Stelle wir in
dem weiteren Verlauf der Dinge auch das
Gesetzgebungsverfahrens zu Verständigung
kommen werden und wo auch nicht ich
glaube er wüsste das eben gesagt er weil
hat es von der ausführlich gesagt alle
wissen schon ganz genau das ist schon
eine ordentliche Nummer die der Bund da
macht 250 Milliarden ist nicht wenig
Geld und das soll zur Entlastung der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dienen und das
ist der Beitrag den der Bund dort
leistet und mein Eindruck ist dass wir
breit anerkannt
ich denke alle Beteiligten die heute
nach Berlin gekommen sind wussten dass
dies noch nicht die schlussberatung sein
kann warum weil mit der gaspreisbremse
und den nachfolgenden bremsen die wir
bei den
Energiekosten haben natürlich eine
Unzahl von Folgewirkungen für andere
Themen verbunden ist deswegen muss man
tatsächlich am Anfang wissen wie genau
funktioniert die energiepreisbremse was
genau sind die Konsequenzen wer wird wie
begünstigt damit man dann
vernünftigerweise die weiteren Maßnahmen
treffen kann das halte ich für absolut
plausibel also ich jedenfalls habe nicht
erwartet nach den vorangegangenen
Beratungen dass wir jetzt an dieser
Stelle
und plötzlich unabhängig von diesen
Themen alles andere lösen könnten das
wäre nicht realistisch gewesen wichtig
ist aus meiner Sicht folgendes erstens
eine prinzipielle Frage ist jetzt
entschieden wird der Staat mit allem was
er kann jetzt in den nächsten Monaten
seinen Teil dazu beitragen dass die
Auswirkungen der energiepreiskrise
gedeckelt werden die Antwort lautet ja
da ist mit dem 200 milliardenprogramm
der Bundesregierung eine überzeugende
Antwort gegeben worden und ich habe
übrigens subjektiv den Eindruck das ist
auch bei vielen Menschen ausdrücklich
angekommen und die zweite Frage ist die
wann genau werden wir wissen wie es denn
ist dass wir dafür wissen müssen wie das
Modell der der gaspreisbremse ausschaut
liegt auf der Hand
es ist auch richtig aus meiner Sicht
dass wir jetzt nicht versuchen im
politischen Hinterzimmer darüber eine
Entscheidung herbeizuführen sondern dass
das über eine Expertenkommission
tatsächlich sehr gründlich vorbereiten
wird das ist ja kein triviales Thema und
bei dem leisten wir uns hoffe ich dürfen
wir uns keine Fehlern erlauben das ist
etwas was wirklich fundamental ist und
auch insofern ist es nicht verwunderlich
dass wir heute nicht zu abschließenden
Entscheidungen kommen und der dritte
Punkt ist ebenfalls ein ganz
wesentlicher wir haben es ja mutmaßlich
doch mit einer spürbaren Eintrübung auch
der steuerlichen Erwartungen zu tun das
was bis jetzt Gegenstand der Stellung
ist das dürfte wahrscheinlich doch um
einiges nach unten zu korrigieren sein
und das bestimmt natürlich auch mit die
Handlungsmöglichkeit nicht nur das
Bundes sondern insbesondere auch der
Länder wir als Länder erwarten dass nach
einem nicht ungünstigen haushaltsverlauf
2022 sich die Verhältnisse in den Jahren
23 24 wesentlich nach unten korrigieren
werden und das ist natürlich dann auch
für unsere Position ein maßgeblich eine
maßgebliche Frage mit anderen Worten
Bürgerinnen und Bürger können sicher
sein dass Bund und Länder gemeinsam
alles tun möglichst schnell die Kleid zu
schaffen die jenseits der großen Summe
auch jeder einzelne für sich haben
möchte das ist ein berechtigter Anspruch
von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern und
gleichzeitig ist es ein hartes Stück
Arbeit das leisten ist eine komplizierte
Materie und wir müssen wirklich maximal
Wert darauf legen dass am Ende die
Ergebnisse auch durch die Bank belastbar
sind deswegen glaube ich das waren
sinnvolle Beratung und ich jedenfalls
bin zufrieden und siehe was mich angeht
mich in meinen Erwartungen bestätigt
aber das ist ja dann vom Person zu
Person unterschiedlich
nächste Frage
an die charmantgen rnd
erste Frage an Herrn Bundeskanzler warum
muss denn
die flüchtlingsfinanzierung und auch die
Frage der Regionalisierungsmittel denn
wiedervertagt werden weil das ist ja
eigentlich unabhängig von
der gaspreisbremse ja also das kann man
ja auch davon unabhängig betrachten und
die zweite Frage noch an Herrn weil die
sagten ja die Not bei den Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern ist sehr groß man muss denn
die gaspreisbremse spätestens kommen um
diese Not zu lindern
es gibt ja für diese ganzen Fragen
Zeitpläne die wir miteinander besprochen
haben zur flüchtlingsfinanzierung ist
verabredet miteinander zu reden und
spätestens im November eine gemeinsame
Grundlage zu schaffen das wird auch
gelingen da bin ich ganz ganz zufällig
und deshalb glaube ich ist das schon
richtig und zu den Maßnahmen über die
wir miteinander diskutieren gehören
natürlich auch die Fragen des
öffentlichen Verkehrs das ist schon
immer ein Thema gewesen zwischen Bund
und Ländern das hat immer schon ein
bisschen Zeit gebraucht bis es gut
geworden ist und so ist es auch jetzt
wenn ich mich recht erinnere wollten sie
wissen wann ich glaube wann wir so weit
werden
sie kommen muss die Antwort lautet so
schnell wie möglich
das führt zu der Frage wann wird es
möglich sein nachdem was wir gehört
haben gehe ich davon aus Ende des Monats
Anfang des nächsten Monats also am 27
Oktober so ist der das Datum wo die
Steuerschätzung vorliegt danach muss es
sehr schnell gehen so dass wir dann
hoffentlich auch schon noch im November
den Beginn von gesetzgebungsberatung
haben werden und in jedem Fall dieses
gesamte Paket nach meiner Erwartung
jetzt im November spätestens Dezember
dann auch tatsächlich
beschlossen werden kann so dass
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dann auch
wirklich an dieser Stelle Klarheit haben
und zu Beginn des Jahres niemand unruhig
schlafen muss weil er jedenfalls weiß
wie die Verhältnisse sind das ist glaube
ich der entscheidende Punkt des Ganzen
tempo- und Qualität miteinander und ein
Unterhalt unter einen Hut zu bringen
daran arbeiten alle intensiv
die letzte Frage
soweit die
Pressekonferenz nach der
Ministerpräsidenten und
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz von Stefan
weil von Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz und
auch von Hendrik wüst ich habe für euch
hier auch das hat mir gerade haben wir
gerade die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ausgedrückt auch noch mal die
Beschlussvorlage vorliegen und ihr habt
es auch gerade gehört und was hier am
Ende nach der Zusammenfassung der
Beschlüsse steht als Ergebnis an Punkt
11 ganz zum Schluss der Bundeskanzler
und die Regierungschefin und
Regierungschefs der Länder treffen
zeitnah erneut zusammen um dann weiter
zu beraten so jetzt hat Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz auffällig oft von sehr
konstruktiven Gesprächen gesprochen und
auch von dem Schulterschluss man hatte
da den Eindruck das wäre Friede Freude
Eierkuchen und jetzt hat auf der anderen
Seite auch Stefan weil das bestätigt bei
uns im Chat treten aber andere
Kommentare auf die Eindrücke aus der
Bevölkerung des ist zum Beispiel von
vakustak sie sind sich einig aber keiner
weiß über was wir haben ja Zeit ironisch
dextramottes auf Youtube oh Mann ich
dachte es wird mal konkret Nicole
Diekmann hat das auch für uns verfolgt
liebe Nicole was war das jetzt war das
eben dieser Schulterschluss diese
konstruktive Konstruktivität die Scholz
angesprochen hat oder war es eben doch
die Enttäuschung wie wir sie hier im
Chat lesen es war ein Schulterschluss
zwischen Olaf Scholz und Stefan weil
gerade in der Pressekonferenz was nicht
weiter verwunderlich ist weil beide ja
Funktionäre in der SPD sind und außerdem
Stefan weil am Sonntag in Niedersachsen
gerne wiedergewählt werden möchte als
Ministerpräsident die beiden haben also
von sehr konstruktiven Gesprächen
gesprochen und das klang auch alles du
hast es gerade ja schon gesagt erst mal
so vom von der Stimmung her ganz okay
was man aber rausfinden konnte war sehr
deutlich dass man heute zu ungefähr gar
keinem Ergebnis gekommen ist sondern zu
dem Ergebnis dass man sich nicht einigen
kann und dass man sich wieder treffen
muss und dann kam Hendrik wüst ins Spiel
anders als Ste weil und Olaf Scholz ist
Hendrik wüst nicht in der SPD sondern in
der CDU und der hat relativ schnell das
zunichte gemacht was seine beiden
Vorredner versucht hatten Entschuldigung
zu etablieren nämlich das Bild einer
weitestgehend ergebnislosen aber sehr
freundlichen Runde beziehungsweise
konstruktiven Runde wüst sagte sehr
schnell ohne Umschweife die Länder sein
mit ausgestreckter Hand ich habe es mir
aufgeschrieben sein konstruktiv und mit
ausgestreckter Hand auf dem Bund
zugegangen und dieser Bund habe sich
kompromisslos gezeigt da war die
Enttäuschung da hat er nicht versucht
irgendein Hehl draus zu machen und das
ich glaube das ist auch der Eindruck der
jetzt von dieser Pressekonferenz bleiben
wird man hat sich getroffen vergangene
Woche haben sich die Länder getroffen
ohne den Bundeskanzler der Corona hatte
und mit der Begründung er wolle gerne
persönlich bei dem Treffen dabei sein
darum gebeten hat das Treffen mit ihm
dann
Grammatik auf ein paar Tage später zu
verschieben nun hat man das getan und
bei diesem Treffen ist ich wiederhole
das noch mal nichts rausgekommen
außerdem Termin Ende Oktober Anfang
November an dem man sich dann wieder
zusammensetzen will
du hast gerade thematisiert dass Hendrik
wüst von der ausgestreckten Hand
gesprochen hat ich hatte gerade auch
noch den Blick auf das
pressekonferenzbild was danach noch lief
das konnten wir jetzt hier gerade nicht
sehen aber auch da war auffällig dass
als alle sozusagen die Tische verlassen
haben Hendrik wüst schon weg war und
Scholz und nur weil sich sozusagen die
Hand gegeben hat also deutliche Kritik
von Hendrik wüst er hat das was Du
angesprochen gesagt dass da nichts
rausgekommen ist wird das denn wird das
denn mit Blick auf die zwei Wochen dann
konkreter oder wird das dann bei diesem
Stand bleiben was glaubst du da
die Frage habe ich nicht verstanden
kannst du die anders formulieren ja also
ich meine bekommen wir in zwei Wochen
dann konkretere Ergebnisse oder glaubst
du das wird jetzt länger dauern nach
diesem Eindruck dieser Pressekonferenz
ich glaube das lässt sich den Leuten da
draußen wirklich nicht verkaufen man
muss noch einmal sagen das gehört auch
zur Wahrheit natürlich machen Scholz und
weil gerade weil Parteipolitik wobei
eben zwischenzeitlich finde ich auch der
Eindruck entstanden ist dass weil auch
sehr viel Wahlwerbung für Olaf Scholz
gemacht hat und immer wieder betont hat
wie toll diese gaspreisbremse sein wird
die es ja noch gar nicht gibt auch
Henrik wüst macht Parteipolitik es ist
klar dass er seine Enttäuschung
sehr klar formuliert denn die
Unionsländer die Union die
Unionsparteien treiben natürlich die
Ampelkoalition vor sich her sowie eine
Opposition das macht es wird
dem Volk es wird den Wählerinnen und
Wählern den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
nicht zu vermitteln sein sich Ende des
Monats wieder zusammenzusetzen und in
einer solchen dramatischen Lage die man
da ja eben auch skizziert hat und
gleichzeitig dann auch skizziert hat mit
welchen wuchtigen Mitteln man diese
dramatische Lage zu bekämpfen
plant das ist ja das Stichwort
dass das wird nicht gehen zu sagen wir
sind in einer unfassbar dramatischen
Lage deswegen nehmen wir wahnsinnig viel
Geld in die Hand aber leider ist jetzt
Ende Oktober Anfang November und wir
haben uns wieder auf nichts geeinigt das
wird auch aus zwei praktischen Gründen
nicht gehen das sind zwei Termine der
eine Termin
der waagetermin ist das kommende Woche
das hat man jetzt eben auf der
Pressekonferenz auch noch mal in
Aussicht gestellt die Kommission die die
gaspreisbremse ausarbeitet im Moment
Ergebnisse vorstellen soll dass das eine
und das andere ist dass am 27 Oktober
die Steuerschätzung erwartet wird das
heißt da hat man dann zwei sehr konkrete
wie soll ich das sagen Parameter mit
deren Hilfe man sich dann Ende des
Monats anfangen November zusammensetzt
und dann tatsächlich Tacheles reden kann
denn was Hendrik wüst auch gemacht hat
ist sich enttäuscht darüber zu zeigen
dass man heute in dieser Runde nichts
konkreteres über die gaspreisbremse
erfahren hat das ist auch Parteitaktik
denn das kann er nicht wirklich erwartet
haben er kennt den Zeitplan es hieß bis
heute Mittag als Robert Habeck in einer
Pressekonferenz gesagt hat die
Ergebnisse der Kommission zu Erarbeitung
der gaspreisbremse würden jetzt
vorgezogen auf kommende Woche vorher
hieß es Ende des Monats also Hendrik
wüst kann nicht erwartet haben heute
mehr zu erfahren auch das gehört
natürlich zu Politik dazu
so jetzt haben wir beide schon
rausgearbeitet dass es in diesen ganzen
Prozess der Diskussion rund um die
entlastungspakete sich schon Risse auf
der einen Seite in der Ampelkoalition
gezeigt haben jetzt kann man heute sagen
es zeigen sich auch Risse zwischen Bund
und Ländern Nicole was sagt das über die
aktuelle politische Situation aus und
auch die Lösungen ja oder Antworten
dieser Krise zu finden tja das ist sehr
sehr schwierig ist dass die
Ampelkoalition keine Wunsch Heirat war
aber das wusste man ja von Anfang an die
aber auch als
erstmalig in dieser Konstellation
regierende
Parteienkonstellation in einer Zeit
geraten ist mit unglaublichen
Herausforderungen haben gestartet mit
Corona Corona ist ja auch noch nicht
vorbei und dann über viel Russland die
Ukraine und es zeigt einfach wie
Wahl getrieben Politik ist
es hätte sich sicherlich heute einiges
anders angehört in dieser
Pressekonferenz würde am Sonntag in
Niedersachsen nicht gewählt
sagt Nicole Dieckmann aus unserem
ZDF-Hauptstadtstudio herzlichen Dank für
deine Analysen für deine Zeit für deine
Einschätzungen auch den Ausblick den du
gegeben hast
ich glaube ich zitiere zum Schluss noch
mal den Kommentar der wahrscheinlich das
Gefühl von vielen von euch widerspiegelt
von Dexter Mortis oh Mann ich dachte es
wird mal konkret nicole hat aber
angesprochen dass in zwei Wochen wenn
sich Bund und Länder dann noch einmal zu
einer weiteren Ministerpräsidenten und
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
Zusammentreffen sollen dass dann
eigentlich dass dieser Auftritt wie er
heute war dann nicht mehr geht das war
ihre Analyse und dann sind wir mal
gespannt was uns dort dann präsentiert
wird vielen Dank fürs zuschauen heute
fürs mitdiskutieren fürs kommentieren
und auch für eure Fragen hat mich sehr
gefreut dass ihr dabei gewesen seid bis
zum nächsten Mal tschüss